[Music]
John wick chapter three Parabellum
trailer has just received worldwide
release and it looks like fans of the
franchise are in for a treat
obviously there's a lot to unpack from
the film's trailer and throughout this
video I'll be breaking down everything
that you need to know about the new
preview there may be some spoilers here
so if you don't want to know anything
about the film and I highly recommend
that you turn off now but for everyone
else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I watch it so you don't
have to it appears that the movie picks
up right after the events of John wick
Chapter two
wick is on the run with the one hour
head start for breaking the central rule
after taking a life on continental
grounds at the end of the previous film
wick now has a fourteen million dollar
contract on his head and it's clear from
the trailer that almost every assassin
on earth is gunning for him whilst he
will initially have to make it out of
New York in one piece shots from the
film highlight that this will be a
globe-trotting adventure unlike the
previous films
John is completely cut off from using
the continental services after having
been made excommunicate oh in the prior
movie this was highlighted in the
recently released poster image for the
film which shows the continental text
reversed as wick is on the other side of
the door this clearly symbolizes that
the character has been completely cut
off and is now in opposition in to their
way of life alongside Reeves in the roll
stars Laurence Fishburne Halle Berry and
Angelica Huston as a mysterious
character and known as the director
hiroyuki sanada is playing films film I
would imagine that some of the film
takes place in Japan at some point due
to the swords we see throughout the
trailer and the choice of villain a
Parabellum is a firearm cartridge that
was designed by George Luger and
introduced in 1902 by the
and weapons manufacturer this could also
highlight that the film may take place
in Germany or Europe similar to John
wick to you other things we know are
Barry's character has a dog so it's safe
to say that she is probably one of the
good guys
common is unfortunately sitting this one
out so the grudge match that was set up
in the second film will not pay off here
Ruby Rose however is returning which
will provide an interesting dynamic it's
unknown whether wick will actually
survive this one and with stars
announcing their spinoff series which
does not feature the hitman it seems
like this maybe one impossible task that
is too much for him back to the trailer
itself we see wick running through the
streets of New York with his dog and we
know that he rides horseback at some
point - judging by behind-the-scenes
footage I think it will use this as a
way to get back to Laurence Fishburne's
character for aid in other behind the
scene images we have seen him being
attacked by a Japanese assassin so
appears that he will indeed help him out
the high table wants his life and
seemingly will do anything to get it
which the director seems to be unable to
help him with we also see him walking
through a desert probably to meet with
Halle Berry's character no doubt he and
Halle Berry's character will be trying
to level the playing field with the high
table and I can't wait to see how this
plays out in the final film obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on the
trailer and what you expect to see in
the film if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and check out my
breakdown of the recent Spider Man far
from home trailer which will be linked
at the end this is the channel for
people who were mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]